un cauchemar nommé total c'est le nom
d'un rapport publié le 20 octobre
dernier par les ong sur mich et les amis
de la terre dans ce document les
associations pointent du doigt deux
projets de la firme total
le premier le projectile en ga en
ouganda il inclut le forage et
l'exploitation de 400 puits dont 132 se
trouverait selon le rapport dans un parc
naturel protégé du pays
le second l'icop un projet de
construction d'un gigantesque oléoduc de
pétrole brut le plus long pape line
chauffer au monde qui traverserait
l'ouganda et la tanzanie
problème selon une enquête menée par les
deux ong à l'origine du rapport ces deux
projets entraînerait des déplacements
massifs de population et l'accaparement
de leurs terres selon les témoignages
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
sont privées de leurs terres avant même
d'avoir reçu la moindre compensation sur
les témoignages collectés
cela fait plus de deux ans qu'elle se
retrouve donc sans aucun moyen de
subsistance entraînant des situations de
famine et de déscolarisation de
nombreuses personnes dénoncent d'avoir
subi des pressions et intimidations pour
signer les formulaires de cession de
leurs terres et disent ne pas savoir
quand ni parfois même combien elles vont
être indemnisés pour racheter de
nouvelles terres et culture outre la
violation des droits humains les ong
pointent aussi du doigt les dommages
irréversibles de ces deux projets sur
l'environnement le projet tient gamme
est donc en danger la biodiversité du
parc des moeurs chez sal falls les cours
d'eau dont les communautés dépendent
pour leur quotidien le lac albert qui
contient environ 30% des pêcheries en
ouganda ainsi que les sols dont les
paysans dépendent pour l'agriculture et
l'air qu'il respire
l'oléoduc menace donc l'accès à l'eau et
à la nourriture deux millions de
personnes dans la région
il traversera des forêts des zones
humides et des mangroves participants la
déforestation à la destruction de la
biodiversité et des moyens de
subsistance des communautés locales
ainsi qu'au réchauffement climatique
total s'est défendu face à ces
accusations
la firme indique notamment que ces deux
projets ont été conçus dans le souci de
minimes
les impacts sur les communautés locales
le plan de vigilance de total identifie
clairement les risques pour les droits
de l'homme les libertés fondamentales la
santé et la sécurité des personnes et
l'environnement qui pourraient résulter
de nos activités
total est pleinement conscient des
impacts potentiels sur les communautés
locales
un dialogue transparent permanent
garantie que toutes les préoccupations
exprimées sont traités de manière
appropriée
l'année dernière les ong les années de
la terre et survie notamment porte la
faire devant les tribunaux elle souhaite
que total applique son devoir de
vigilance souvenez-vous ce texte de loi
a été introduit à l'assemblée nationale
juste après le drame dur à la plaza au
bangladesh
elle oblige les entreprises françaises à
mettre en place des plans de vigilance
pour prévenir les atteintes aux droits
humains ou à l'environnement
le tribunal judiciaire de nanterre s'est
déclaré incompétent pour statuer sur ce
cas et à renvoyer le dossier vers le
tribunal de commerce ce que souhaitait
total les ong ont fait appel l'audience
se tiendra le 28 octobre